il s'agit donc du premier revenant
djihadiste français libéré de prison sur
le territoire c'était donc hier après
cette année je le disais d'incarcération
alors qu'une trentaine un plus d'une
trentaine même de libération sont
attendus cette année
quel traitement est il réservé à ces
détenus condamnés pour terrorisme
islamiste à leur sortie doit-on leur
réserver un suivi particulier durant
l'incarcération mais aussi une fois
qu'ils se retrouvent dans l'espace
public c'est l'objet de notre face à
face ce soir et pour en débattre nous
sommes sur ce plateau avec un habillage
et magna présidente de la brigade des
mers bonsoir nadia relais maintenat
merci date en direct sur arte france
et puis en direct par skype nicolas
moreau chroniqueur chez atlantico merci
à vous aussi d'être présent avec nous à
distance mais ça ne va pas vous empêcher
évidemment de débattre avec nadia redman
a ici présentes sur les studios
parisiens
tout d'abord première rentrée en manier
en matière dans le coeur de ce débat est
ce que selon vous ces prisonniers sont
qu'il des détenus comme les autres
nicolas moreau n'auront clairement pas
parce que ce sont des dépôts qui sont
extrêmement dangereux et qui ressorte en
étant tout aussi dangereux donc
clairement ce sont des sondés des
comptes pour lesquels la détention n'a
absolument rien apporté et ce sont les
détenus qui sont comme nous pour est
radicalisée et pour la plupart qui se
sont radicalisés en prison donc
clairement ou ne vont pas des
radicaliser en maintenant en prison dont
il faut soit on rentrait autre chose
soit les isoler de la société de manière
plus ferme mais on est pour l'instant
donc ne pas les traiter comme les autres
découlent nadia rayman a en gros voilà
ils seront jamais des détenus et des ex
détenus comme les autres il faut
peut-être les i
la société ça on en débattra vrai vous
êtes d'accord avec le diagnostic de
nicolas moreau tout à fait d'accord et
puis après le problème qu'on se passe je
pense qu'on est pas prêt de toute façon
à des fins et réintégrer dans la société
d'utilisation c'est bave et ils veulent
pas de toute façon sera intégré dans la
société et je pense est essentiellement
envie de passer alors pas envie du tout
de toute façon après bon ils ont fait
leurs prises sept ans de prison on va
nous dire bon de toute façon on peut
purger leur peine c'est bon tout ça mais
moi ce qui me fait peur c'est le suivi
parce que le suivi c'est le suivi ce
classique 1 il doit se rendre je pense
une fois par semaine et pointer au
commissariat surveillance judiciaire et
ça c'est le truc classique je marque
pour les petites peines ça c'est un truc
classique on a pas rajouté quelque chose
de plus pour dire effectivement alors on
n'avait qu'à la malaria qu'on va
pardonnez moi un conte en variation avec
juge où il assure des soins pas
d'autorisation tout de même deux
déplacements à surveiller on va pas
mettre vous savez mais je pense
qu'effectivement on n'est pas prêt de
toute façon à accompagner ce genre de
2,2 public j'allais dire de terroristes
on n'est pas plus près et déjà
effectivement déjà il était dans un
contexte pendant sept ans où ils sont
encore plus radicalisés je pense que un
moment donné quand ces gens là dans
celle après sept ans de prison
juste après il faudrait il faudrait
qu'il ya une institution je sais pas un
foyer où quelque chose qui soit encore
surveiller parce qu'on parle de
terrorisme nous parle pas quelqu'un qui
a volé un scooter mais moi
personnellement avec le travail de
terrain que je fais que je suis et j'ai
même moins travailler dans les prisons
oui autres auprès de ce public là je
peux vous dire que on n'est pas prêt on
n'est pas prêts du tout à recevoir ce
genre de public pascal est chez lui
c'est intéressant ce qu'on vous dit
puisque vous êtes au contact de ces
personnes qu'est-ce qui vous permet de
dire ça aujourd'hui qu'est ce que ces
personnes s'est jadis qui sont allés en
syrie vous dise clairement
alors moi ce que ce que ce qu'ils me
disent alors aux 10 effectivement pour
eux c'est toujours le même discours on
est des victimes
rien fait c'est l'injustice on a été
défendre des pauvres malheureux ils ont
tout le monde à ce discours
voilà de victimisation entre guillemets
et après ya l'idéologie qu'on le veuille
ou non elle est là faut pas l'oublier
ils sont convaincus que de toute façon
ils veulent de toute façon islamiser la
france qu'on le veuille ou non de toute
façon pour eux c'est pas qu'un pour eux
en fin de compte c'est comme si qu'ils
étaient des héros pour une se voyait pas
comme délinquants ou hors la loi et se
voyaient comme des héros ils sont en
mission et leur mission ne s'arrête pas
une fois qu'ils sont sortis de prison
alors ce que leur dit le juge ou ce
qu'on va leur mettre en place je pense
que qui s'en foutent chalaisien nicolas
moreau 70 personnes incarcérées pour
terrorisme dont la moitié est
effectivement de serre venant de syrie
quarante deux personnes libérable en
2020 ça vous inspire quoi ces chiffres
sont là un vrai problème puisque les
mesures de suivi sont absolument pas
mais on l'a vu au début de l'année avec
plusieurs plusieurs data exhale à la
suite il suffit d'une demi heure
maintenant pour faire plutôt en bas de
chez soi et qui en attaque d innocence
et pas en allant pointer au commissariat
même tous les jours qu'on peut pas
sortir il faudrait beaucoup plus strict
des âmes et là on est en train en fait
de ne par principe ou par la tipp
on est en train de se créer un problème
qui va être insurmontable on a vu des
vertes et pour les policiers pour leur
enseignement puisque on n'a pas encore
fini d'arrêter les revenant du diable on
n'a pas encore trouvé de solution pour
les djihadistes qui a été incarcéré dans
le nord de la syrie et on est déjà en
train de se créer un autre problème avec
des djihadistes qui sont pas du tout les
radicaliser et et pour quillan mais des
mesures de suivi qui sont absolument pas
adapté au mode opératoire terroriste
actuelle donc commencé effectivement
très inquiétant et
[Musique]
il ya rien de rassurant indiens ont
rassuré des gens sur ce point
effectivement la libérer 40 personnes
qui sont des des tueurs potentiels qui
sont des points hauts potentiels qui
seront sans doute plus sera tout cas
nice mais maintenant qu'ils adorent
entrée en prison et qui pour beaucoup
n'ont plus rien à perdre puisqu'ils vont
avoir des mesures terre en contraignant
qui vous vivent comme des lions en cage
et dès qu'ils auront une occasion de
s'en sortir pour aller pour aller mener
une attaque un certain nombre le ferons
puisque de toute façon ils n'ont plus
rien à perdre et c'est jean lannes sur
la phèdre europe a pas de sitôt enfin
pas pour beaucoup
si je peux me permettre aussi déjà on a
des jeunes moi qui travaille dans les
quartiers tous à des jeunes qui n'ont
pas été en prison sont pas content mais
qui pour moi sont radicalisés et qu'ils
ont pas en prison mais pour moi ont un
discours de radicalisation de toute
façon alors effectivement en france on
punit l'acte la cette personne là parce
qu'elle était en syrie il est en prison
voilà ce que c'est un départ en séries
mais il faut qu'on comprenne il doit
arrêter de se mentir on a une grande
majorité malheureusement je dis bien une
grand majorité qui sont pas partis en
syrie mais qui ont une idéologie et qui
pensent exactement comme cette personne
qui vient de quitter la prison et autres
le problème c'est ça c'est qu'on a une
grande jeunesse qui est radicalisée et
en face de nous on a des gens qui sont
en train de nous dire maintenant les
pauvres malheureux vous êtes méchant
avec eux vous êtes islamophobe et l'on
parle au bas alors tant qu'il y aura pas
un courage politique
moi j'invite ces politiques de venir
dans les quartiers et on a des jeunes
aujourd'hui
leur seul repère c'est le coran le seul
livre qui lisent et qu'ils apprécient
c'est le courant et on a des
professionnels et bas qui savent plus
comment faire et on a aussi des
encadrants des gens qu'ils encadrent ces
jeunes qui eux mêmes et pour cette
idéologie
alors aujourd'hui on n'est pas en face
de petits délinquants ont en face d'eux
des chèques scolaires
on est en face de gens qui et poussines
et épousé une biologie et qu'ils sont
convaincus alors entre ceux qui vont
sortir les retours de série et ceux qui
sont dans notre territoire mais qui
n'ont pas été encore été en prison mais
qui sont radicalisés il n'y a pas que
déjà l'on parle déjà
il ya des femmes et des familles
entières et en même temps aujourd'hui on
a des politiques qui défendent ce genre
de radicalisation après jeu en disant la
radicalisation certainement mais
radicalement et qui justifient par ion
excusez vous avez raison qui justifie en
disant oui bah les pauvres regarder où
est-ce qu'ils habitent regarder ceux ci
repère identitaire on nous invente des
mots mais on doit déjà l'heure je pense
si on aime déjà nos citoyens on aime nos
jeunes gens pouvaient protéger et pour
protéger je pense qu'il faut commencer
très très très très jeune il faut pas
faire de cadeaux je suis désolé il faut
que toute la société s'implique quand
j'ai dit toute la société je parle de
l'éducation nationale des éducateurs et
vous faire attention qui encadrent
d'abord ses jambes ses enfants c'est je
laisse sont pas radicaliser tout seuls
n'y a toujours eu un début alors nous
particulièrement à sevran on avait des
on avait dénoncé on les appelle les
rabatteurs moi personnellement j'avais
alerté le préfet j'ai alerté le maire à
l'époque j'ai alerté tout le monde nous
a dit on m'a dit que non c'était rien
c'était c'était eux des gens qu'ils
avaient droit de pratiquer tout ça alors
moi je voudrais revenir un petit peu en
arrière mais je suis d'origine berbère
j'ai connu le terrorisme en algérie
je connais je sais comment fonctionnent
ces gens là et vont pas venir du jour au
lendemain sont très gentils ils ont pris
en plus des places comme le social et
tout ça ils ont commencé par prendre la
place et le karaté quartier et tout le
monde les aime bien effectivement et
après ils ont ils raison il sait pas
comment vous expliquez que c'est pas un
programme pour demain pour deux ans a eu
longtemps et se disent d'entrants
pendant 40 ans il vole réconquérir mon
histoire de thonon et c'est ça leur but
ils sont pas pressés il y en a cent qui
meurent mais on a 300 qui sont bien eux
c'est comme on forme
vous allez peut-être trouvé dur c'est
comme si confort mais des soldats des
militaires c'est pas on va pas former
des citoyens
je voudrais vous faire écouter puisque
vous êtes d'un avis quasi identique un
contrepoids peut-être le juge
antiterroriste david le pas pour lui les
renseignements ont les moyens de suivre
les avis
les individus à leur sortie de prison
j'entends que l'on puisse avoir des
appréhensions mais comment se protéger
si on ne les a pas sous la main la
meilleure méthode c'est de les juger et
de les contrôler si dans 15 20 30 ans
ces personnes constituent encore une
menace en sortant de prison où est mené
un travail d'évaluation exemplaires ils
resteront sous le contrôle des services
de renseignement et de justice en
nicolas moreau sont jugés assez
optimiste en lui il dit banon en france
on a les moyens on peut les contrôler
vous disiez tout à l'heure justement on
n'a pas les moyens de ce suivi
qu'est ce que vous préconisez auriez
parce que qu'est-ce qu'on en fait de ces
gens une fois qu'ils ont purgé leur
peine
voilà la peine de mort n'existe pas en
france et c'est peut-être parce que vous
souhaitez non plus voilà non la peine de
mort n'existe pas en français n'existent
indirectement quand les djihadistes sont
à l'étranger et et quand tu es quand on
organise des opérations des attaques
contres notamment sur des terrains de
guerre mais sur le terrain purement
français il n'y a pas de solution ce que
ce juge déclare n'est pas ce qui est
appliqué les peines de 15 20 30 ans
n'existent pas ce sont des peines de 7
ans qui s'applique actuellement on aime
le frère de flavien bros qui s'appelle
nicolas moreau qui était un profil à peu
près comparable au sien et ces deux
parts de la famille puisque vous êtes et
vous même nicolas moreau entrée 6
heureusement que j'ai un deuxième prénom
car l'addition pour le coup pour le coup
non c'est un profil beaucoup plus dures
son frère il s'appelle nicolas moreau il
a été il a été condamné à 10 ans de
prison
dix ans en prison seulement donc il ya
pas de 15 20 30 ans avec suivi à 10 ans
de prison pour le suivre là des services
de renseignements qui sont complètement
dépassés enfin jour le pen qui est un
attentat à la préfecture au sein même du
renseignement de la préfecture donc
s'ils n'arrivent pas à suivre un de
leurs collègues qui est complètement
radicaliser je vois pas comment ils vont
suivre et le temps qui ne pensent qu'à
s'échapper et donc les solutions au
niveau macro elles sont évidemment de
refus
des budgets sont doucement pour la
police et la justice parce que la
justice un budget d'à peine 9 milliard
d'euros dont il n'y a pas assez présent
passer du juge ces deux de suivi et
c'est la solution la plus efficace qui
serait très coûteuse et qui serait la
plus difficile à l'eau potable
façon correcte ce sera évidemment
guantanamo à la française c'est à dire
que vous avez un centre spécial ou entre
les djihadistes et pour que ça se passe
pas dans des conditions déplorables de
guantanamo américain il faut énormément
de garde-fous et de et de petits détails
comme avait des délais de traitement des
dossiers qu'ils soient très raccourci
des recours possibles qu'ils soient
soient effectifs etc
et ça ça demande savoir d'une mise en
place qui coûte très cher la loire et
heureusement pour tout ce qui est
régalien n'a pas de budget on a tendance
à dépenser beaucoup plus dans des
éoliennes ou des jeux olympiques ou des
trucs qui peuvent la vivre comme
secondaire et ça fait 40 ans qu'on ne
donne pas correctement leur est gagnant
google
donc aujourd'hui on en paye le prix et
il nous reste des discours assez
rassurant pour tacler français 5e et je
vois qu'en fait qui se juge va rassurer
quand il donne son son discours et
puisqu'on annonce en août après une
quarantaine de djihadistes tout aussi
dangereux que flavie amoureux vont être
pour être libérés cette année je vais
vous faire écouter une solution qui se
rapproche peut-être d'ailleurs de la
vôtre c'était par des voix de la droite
aujourd'hui qui elle suggère des centres
de rétention écouté il faudrait élargir
la rétention de sûreté aux djihadistes
aux personnes condamnées pour
radicalisation pour acte de terrorisme
mais également à ceux qui reviennent de
ces théâtres de guerre pour des détenus
condamnés pour terrorisme ou pour droit
commun mais qui ont été identifié comme
islamiste dangereux
on doit étudier au cas par cas des
mesures de rétention de sûreté
le français flavien moreau condamnés
pour terrorisme islamistes libérés ce 13
janvier 2019 après sept ans en prison
aucune action pour renforcer la
rétention de sûreté n'a été mise en
place par hollande macron pour protéger
les français malgré nos demandes
réitérées 1 il ya redman à 7
rétention de sûreté est ce que c'est un
fantasme de la droite mais c'est aussi
des politiques la droite aussi a été au
pouvoir et la droite aussi a fait des
erreurs vont effectivement on est en
pleine minicipal mois et puis moi j'ai
travaillé dans les villes de droite où
effectivement on a dénoncé tout ça je
peux vous dire que la droite quand on
est là dans la ville et dans les
quartiers elle a complètement un autre
discours
c'est pas du tout le discours qu'ils en
viennent au contraire ils ont exactement
le même discours ils ont ils ont adhéré
aussi un moment donné moi je connais
très bien
j'ai travaillé dans les villes comme lui
dit quand il s'appelle le seul à garder
tout ça qu'on a alerté je peux vous dire
quand ils sont sur place ils ont un
autre discours quand ils sont deux faces
de ce public là pour la raison c'est du
clientélisme sinon cette façon déjà
gagné au terrain sinon c'est du
clientélisme effectivement c'est pour ça
qu'on a énormément de ce problème parce
que c'est par intérêt électoral parce
qu'ils pensent d'abord à eux d'abord et
le peuple après et malheureusement c'est
l'arroseur arrosé ils ont nourri le
monstre et la bête pardon et la bête est
devenu un monstre un moment donné il
pensait qu'il suffisait de faire une
mosquée il suffisait de faire un iftar
république un iftar c'est qu'on rompe le
jeûne pendant le ramadan
il suffisait de leur faire une petite
boucherie par ci une petite douche qui
par là pour que les mets et c'est ça
tout le monde a participé alors la
droite aujourd'hui donnent des leçons
mais faut pas oublier qu'en 2005 sommes
quand même si sarkozy était au pouvoir
la première des choses qu'il a retiré la
police de proximité et il nous a mis la
politique des grands frères alors je
voudrais dire à la droite je pense que l
a été au pouvoir et qu'elle a échoué
aussi comme la gauche c'était un échec
cuisant pour vous la politique des
grands faire ça pouvait être sur le oui
oui parce qu'effectivement et ça
continue parce que mais malheureusement
la politique des grands frères déjà
c'était les frères restés les hommes les
femmes et s'était exclu et la politique
des grands frères s'étaient qui au début
des grands frères c'est elle qui caïd de
quartier qui vous devez calme et entre
guillemets les moins les petits
effectivement après leurs amis des
comptes rend leur a donné des
responsabilités après ce sont politisés
et puis après on a négocié avec eux et
puis les la politique des grands frères
c'était bien le discours de
victimisation ce n'était pas un discours
de aux républicains comme on dit
aujourd'hui
a peur de dire certaines choses pourquoi
pour renault parce que c'est nous qui
sommes traiter d'islamophobe et j'en
passe et j'en passe aujourd'hui je pense
qu'il manque un courage politique et
j'allais dire aussi qu'on a un courage
aussi de certains journalistes
je pense aussi parce que j'allais finir
justement alors il manque aussi un
courage de certains journalistes qui il
suffit de taper dans le terrain et puis
et puis après la justice effectivement
elle a laissé assez clément pour
certains chose est plus sévère je trouve
pour des choses vraiment pour la par
exemple pour la liberté d'expression
condamner quelqu'un pour la liberté
d'expression et essayer parce que je
pense qu'aujourd'hui à l'opinion
publique et les réseaux sociaux s'est
allégée on a peur de l'opinion publique
malheureusement on oublie qu'il ya eu il
ya eu charlie les attentats il ya eu un
prêtre quand même qui est mort dont on a
égorgé un prêtre dans l'église imaginer
le contraire qu'on aurait égorgé un imam
dans une mosquée où vous rendez compte
comment on aurait réagi pour la mort où
justement on a maintenant fait référence
à l'opinion publique j'allais y venir
parce que il ya celle peut-être qu'ils
jugent qui est entre guillemets bien
pensante peut-être mais il ya aussi
celle qui n'a pas du tout envie de voir
ces personnes revenir d'irak et jeu sauf
erreur elles sont absolument majoritaire
dans notre pays un des récents sondages
ont montré que les français donc pas
envie que ces djihadistes reviennent sur
le sol est ce que c'est de là que
viendra peut-être la solution puisque
nadia nous expliquer clairement de
courage politique est-ce que ça va venir
des citoyens qui vont prendre
voilà conscience de ce danger de ce
problème selon vous ça sera le mauvais
temps non non non parce que maintenant
ensemble
en fait depuis 2015 on a beaucoup
progressé sur le sur l'islamisme sur le
terrorisme sur les méthodes sur les
méthodes des frères musulmans sur les
méthodes des salafistes sur sur une
infiltration terroriste la
radicalisation on a beaucoup progressé
et je pense qu'il ya vraiment beaucoup
de connaissances au niveau des français
sur tous ces sujets malheureusement on
en est arrivé dans une phase où la
réalité tellement effrayante
l'écrasante majorité des français essaye
de ne pas la voir
c'est à dire qu'ils se cachent les yeux
il se bouche les oreilles il se tait il
essaye de faire sa vie comme si tout ça
n'existait pas et donc il n'y a pas
vraiment de pression populaire
sur ces sujets quelques sondages nous
semble un petit peu c'est oublier au
bout de deux jours et des français c'est
vraiment de faire leur vie de manière à
aller au travail le matin à payer leurs
emprunts à assurer l'éducation de leurs
enfants mais essaye à tout prix
d'oublier au maximum que charlie a eu
lieu d'oublier au maximum que tous ces
attentats ont eu lieu et en conséquence
en fait on n'avance pas du tout on en
revient aujourd'hui cinq ans après
charlie au discours qu'il y avait en
c'est à dire de dire que finalement
charles il a un petit peu cherché que
vous avez quand même provoqué avec leurs
caricatures et puis dans le contexte
actuel comme ça a été bien soulignée par
l'humaniste c'est que les élections qui
sont les pires du point de l'écrit hanté
l'isthme qui sont des élections locales
municipales arrive dans trois mois donc
là tout le monde marche sur des oeufs
puisque la dernière fois aux élections
il ya eu pas mal de villes de l'ancienne
banlieues rouges qui sont tombées aux
mains de la droite de du pays parce que
la droite et le pays avait misé sur un
clientélisme vis-à-vis de l'électorat
musulman et effectivement il ya eu ces
fameuses politique des grands frères
dont on avait parlé des constructions de
mosquées et cetera des promesses à la
communauté musulmane en considérant
qu'ils n'ont commenté me louer puisque
ça a marché la dernière fois notamment
dans la banlieue rouge parisienne est le
nom de ce mois a été a été relevée
puisque ça avance elle avait besoin
d'une refonte est donc là on est dans
une période où il ya absolument aucun
risque qui est pris sur ce sujet aucun
poids politique tout ce qui est fait
c'est vraiment de de miser à fond sur le
mac ont violement et d'essayer de gagner
ces villes qui sont des villes qui
peuvent basculer
contrairement à d'autres bastions qui
sont là qui sont plus installés
ça sera le mot de la fin en tout cas
merci à vous nadia est maintenant
nicolas moreau à distance d'avoir été
avec nous pour débattre parler de ce
sujet merci à vous deux merci